egyptian mummies chinese mummies the
scorpion king ever wonder how all these
undead characters fit together and what
about the adventurers trying to find
them keep watching for an explanation of
the entire timeline of the mummy
franchise
the story of the mummy franchise begins
over 5000 years before rick o'connell
battled the titular egyptian priest
imhotep in the 1920s
around the year 3087 bc a boy named
matthias is an acadian child who's
destined to become the man known all
over the ancient world as the scorpion
king he's also a 13 year old with
ambitions of becoming a black scorpion
this elite unit served the kingdom of
akkad and protected its leader from harm
though it was far from a glamorous life
when the trainer of the scorpions the
battle heart and sargon discovered that
matthias's female friend layla had snuck
into the training sessions in disguise
he wasn't happy he told the girl that
there were no female scorpions and
expelled her which angered mathias the
youngster lashed out at sargon and asher
was forced to defend his son from him
king hamurabi stepped in to stop the
scuffle before someone got hurt but the
chassen sagon swore revenge on asher
using his dark magic sargon killed
matthias's dad in a cowardly attack
seven years after the murder of his
father a 20-year-old matthias finished
his training and became a fully fledged
black scorpion the ruler of akkad had
been killed and usurped by sargon who
then used the cursed arrow to kill
matthias's younger brother noah
[Applause]
the now grown-up layla confirmed to
matthias that sargon was using dark
magic and that they would need a special
weapon to defeat him leaving a cod
behind mathias journeyed to the
underworld to retrieve the sword of
damocles after burning off his black
scorpion tattoo with it he used the
legendary weapon to take revenge on the
man that killed his father and brother
akkad quickly fell into ruin after the
reign of the evil usurper sargon by 3077
bc there were only three akkadians left
matthias his half brother jessop and
their friend rama they earned a living
as mercenaries in the years following
the collapse of akkad gaining a fearsome
reputation
they were not quite as feared as the
great swordsman and warlord memnon
however memnon had cut a bloody path
across the known world using the
predictions of a sorcerer named
cassandra to stay one step ahead of his
enemies in a last-ditch effort to stop
him king pharaoh of the free tribes
hired the last accordions to kill the
sorcerer the akkadian successfully
located cassandra but jessup and rama
were killed by mimnon's men who were
tipped off by king pharaon's turncoat
son matthias managed to escape with his
life and the sorcerer who it turned out
was an unwilling accomplice to mimnon's
conquest she used her magic to save
matthias from an arrow dipped in
scorpion venom but it changed him
forever
the blood of the scorpion will always
flow through his veins
she predicted that he would likely die
if he faced mimnon though matthias beat
the odds defeating the warlord and
becoming the new ruler of gomorrah the
city's troops dubbed him the scorpion
king
matthias married cassandra after they
took down memnon and they enjoyed a
period of peace and prosperity but it
would not last nothing lasts forever my
king
when we next caught up with matthias in
2012's the scorpion king 3 battle for
redemption we learned that cassandra was
among the many who perished from a
deadly plague that brought his kingdom
to its knees mathias returned to his
life as a mercenary and found himself in
the employee of another ruler king aorus
of egypt had a job for matthias to stop
his upstart younger brother talis who is
planning to usurp him with magic mathias
traveled to the far east to face talus
and defeated him despite talus using the
black book to raise warriors from the
dead in an attempt to give him the upper
hand
years after taking out talus mathias got
a new job from a new king he was sent to
find and acquire an artifact known as
the urn of kings which he did but not
without a fight during the scuffle his
apprentice drozen proved himself to be a
traitor who was after the urn it's
revealed later that inside the urn is
the golden key of lord alchemin and it
leads to alchemin's crown which gives
the wearer unimaginable power drazen
killed his own father and tried to frame
matthias all in an attempt to get the
crown for himself but it's all to no
avail mathias found out the location of
the crown 2 and witnesses drazen meet
his own demise after seeing its power
first hand he reported back that it was
just a myth and locked it away again for
the good of humanity turns out it was
just a campfire story
the last adventure the scorpion king
would go on before his ill-fated assault
on thebes was when matthias teamed up
with a female warrior named tala in 2018
scorpion king book of souls the film
pits matthias against tala's brother
nebzarik who has raided the tomb of the
ancient king memtep to acquire the fang
of anubis nebzarek planned on using it
to rule the world but that wasn't the
only thing on his to-do list he also
wanted the scorpion king dead the only
way to neutralize the fang of anubis was
to use it to stab the book of souls but
that became more complicated when
matthias learned that the book was not
actually a book but a person memtep's
daughter was the living embodiment of
the book and she ultimately sacrificed
herself to break the curse and free the
trapped souls
after years of trying to avoid violence
losing so many friends and loved ones
took its toll on matthias by the year
3067 bc he had resumed the title of
scorpion king and assembled a massive
army intent on taking over the known
world and imposing his rule as seen in
the prologue to the mummy returns he led
an assault on the great city of thebes
but failed to take the city after a
brutal bloody campaign that lasted for
seven years he and his army were
defeated and driven into the sacred
desert of amshir under the blistering
sun his men began dropping like flies
until only matthias himself remained
alone angry and desperate he called on
anubis and made him an offer grant the
power to defeat his enemies once and for
all and he could have his soul anubis
accepted an oasis sprang up around
matthias saving his life anubis gave him
command of his army and he made easy
work of those who defied him taking
thebes with little effort as soon as the
city fell however anubis collected the
debt the scorpion king was taken to the
underworld now bound to serve the dark
god
many years later in 1290 bc to be exact
pharaoh seti the first high priest
imhotep entered into a secret affair
with his lord's concubine enoch soon the
moon she spent her days painted with an
intricate gold pattern one that easily
smudged if anyone touched her seti would
know when he noticed that she had been
touched and began to grill her about it
imhotep acted he and anak sunamun
stabbed the pharaoh to death as his
daughter watched on from an adjacent
balcony she alerted her father's guards
and rather than be captured hanaksu
namoon committed suicide imhotep was
spirited away by his followers and made
it his mission to resurrect his lover he
stole the book of the dead but the magi
stopped him before he could complete the
ritual he was sentenced to the most
brutal punishment of the day the ham
died the victim's tongue was cut out and
they were mummified alive with a bunch
of flesh-eating scarab beetles thrown
into the sarcophagus for good measure
in the year 200 bc emperor han of
ancient china set in motion the events
that would play out on screen in the
mummy tomb of the dragon emperor han
wanted to live forever so he sought the
help of the powerful sorcerer c-u-n the
sorcerer was sent on a mission to
retrieve some magic scrolls that would
help her grant the emperor's wish with
han's top general ming guo watching over
her they were gone for some time and
after they opened up to one another they
fell in love this didn't sit well with
han who believed that yuin belonged to
him and him alone when their affair was
discovered guo was put to death in
horrific circumstances han had his
general ripped apart by horses to unlimb
from limb having gotten everything he
needed from un han then stabbed the
sorcerer which would be the last thing
he did for many years what han didn't
realize is that yuwin had taken out an
insurance policy against such a thing
she secretly cursed the emperor and his
army so that if he ever harmed her they
would all be turned into statues clay
began pouring from han's eyes after he
plunged his blade into the sorcerer and
his men became the famous terracotta
army
the descendants of pharaoh seti the
first sacred bodyguards spent years
watching over humanotra the resting
place of the treacherous priest imhotep
making sure that nobody brought the
cursed one back to life hamunoptra had
become a legend in that time with many
doubting it even existed in 1923 a.d an
army of 12-reg warriors mounted an
attack on the foreign occupiers and then
fled leaving rick o'connell in charge of
the outfit he displayed great bravery
during the battle of hamunoptra but his
men were overwhelmed o'connell was
cornered and was on the verge of being
killed when his trial egg pursuers
became spooked and fled he set off into
the desert alone
against the odds rick o'connell managed
to make it back to civilization but has
luck didn't improve much in the years
following haminoptra in 1926 a british
librarian and egyptologist named evelyn
carnahan sought him out in prison after
her brother the light-fingered jonathan
acquired a map to homonopter from him
rick was seconds from death but evelyn
saved his life by promising the hangman
a cut of the treasure the pair fell in
love as they traveled to the city of the
dead together and their bond was tested
after they discovered imhotep
sarcophagus after accidentally bringing
the cursed priest back to life by
reading from the book of the dead evelyn
became important to imhotep
[Music]
the resurrected villain planned on
finally bringing a knock soon the moon
back from the dead and evie was to be
his human sacrifice he almost succeeded
but against the odds rick jonathan and
evie defeated the creature they used the
book of amera to make imhotep a mortal
man and rick stabbed him in the gut rick
and eevee settled in london after the
event of homonoptra not long after their
escape they had a son alex he is eight
years old when we rejoin the o'connells
and the mummy returns in which his
parents discover the bracelet of anubis
formerly belonging to the scorpion king
it's 1933 which is the year of the
scorpion 5 000 years since the ancient
king was taken to the underworld and
when he is prophesied to return it turns
out the bracelet is a map to the
scorpion king's resting place but alex
didn't know this when he put it on from
that moment he had seven days to enter
the golden pyramid at the center of
amshare if he didn't make it in time his
life force would be sucked from his body
just like all times huh
alex was kidnapped by an egyptian cult
that planned on resurrecting imhotep and
helping him defeat the scorpion king
after saving his son rick used the spear
of osiris to defeat the scorpion king
himself both he and imhotep were about
to be dragged to the underworld but
eevee saved rick the resurrected enoch
sue namoon on the other hand abandoned
imhotep heartbroken he allowed himself
to be taken forever leaving behind the
mortal world
it's 1946 and alex o'connell is all
grown up he takes after his parents in
more ways than one he's a keen explorer
and he has terrible luck when it comes
to resurrecting ancient evils alex
discovered the legendary tomb of the
ancient chinese emperor rahan and
believed him to be nothing more than a
statue he turned out to be unknowingly
working with the people who funded the
trip a rogue faction of the chinese
military that wanted to bring the
tyrannical emperor back to life rick and
evie had been working as spies for the
british government during world war ii
and they were asked to carry out one
last mission return a priceless artifact
called the eye of shangri-la to china
unbeknownst to them the eye was the key
to resurrecting the emperor and after it
was taken from them han was brought back
to life in shanghai they teamed up with
alex and lin a local girl who helped
them locate shangri-la in the himalayas
she turned out to be the daughter of
zuwin who was still alive thanks to the
waters of the mystical mountain utopia
they both sacrificed their immortality
to bring back general ming's army who
battled han's forces it was good old
rick who ultimately stopped the emperor
however killing him with a cursed dagger
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie series are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]